die kanten pflege in deutschland das
einer perversen kafka ersten situation
ausgesetzt das ganze letzte jahr wurde
beteuert dass man jetzt begriffen habe
wie wichtig es ist hier stehen die
mädels seit 25 tagen auf der straße ohne
das gros jemand berichtet
zeitgleich ist es so dass niemand von
den fliegenden in irgendeiner weise mal
nun an dem prozess beteiligt wird in die
sendung eingeladen wird im gegenteil
schauspieler überprüfen jetzt ob das was
fliegende sagen wirklich richtig ist und
schauspieler sind es auch die jetzt nach
einem 2 tages groß für eine schau in die
kliniken gehen liegt kliniken die die
kollegen die medial reden dafür wieder
rauswerfen das ist nicht mehr normal
darüber würde ich gerne reden so
schünemann ich kann ihren ärger nicht so
ganz verstehen denn eigentlich müssten
doch alle die im pflegeberuf tätig sind
sich freuen wenn das was sie machen
auch viele viele menschen interessiert
also wenn auch schauspieler oder
journalisten wer auch immer in die
pflegeheime kommt in die krankenhäuser
um zu sehen wie anstrengend der beruf
ist eben also und ihm die personalie jan
josef liefers auffallen oder aber aber
du hast doch toll wenn jan josef liefers
sagt ich schaue mir das mal an ich meine
was soll jan josef liefers machen so jan
josef liefers einen aus dem juli auch
eingeladen wurde eingeladen aber gerne
josef liefers ist schauspieler ist
künstler ich würde ihm nicht zumuten
wollen schon aus aufgrund der dsd aus
sicht der pflege personen nicht dass jan
josef liefers plötzlich pflegedienste
verrechnet oder würden sie das begrüßen
im gegenteil aber es gibt ja formate die
das durchaus machen ja wo das problem
ist dass diejenigen die auf der arbeit
schon keine zeit mehr haben die
nachwuchs anzuleiten jetzt dazu
verdonnert werden schauspieler an zu
leiden was kafkaesk ist und auf der
anderen seite muss man sich mal vor
augen halten dass pflege in deutschland
immer an vorstellungen festgemacht wird
alles was der deutsche über pflege
glaubt das hat er von der
schwarzwaldklinik gelernt und
krankenschwestern werden immer
runtergebrochen auf einen schwester
stephanie traumbild wenn die realität
dann erst dann gibt es das problem vor
ort nämlich in der klinik und nicht bei
den schauspielern darin kann man
schauspieler in der klinik gerade
überhaupt gar nicht brauchen ich finde
klinik ist entschuldigung der klinik ist
überhaupt gar kein so wenn ich wach
werde will ich dort überhaupt niemanden
sehen außerdem der sich dann wundert
dann müssen sie sich nicht wundern dass
alle leute denken wir haben die
schwarzwaldklinik gesehen das läuft ja
ganz toll also er muss sich was ändern
alle ende da ist öffnen sie sich und
sagen so ist es wirklich oder sie sagen
bitte glaubt
die frage soll es sein warum nach
eineinhalb jahre corona und ich glaube
jeder kann sich vorstellen was in diesen
eineinhalb jahre in kliniken los ist
warum brauchen wir schauspieler und
diese realität irgendwie tron zu
transportieren also ich habe ein jahr
pflege studiert ich habe als student
gearbeitet natürlich nicht vergleichbar
mit die leute die das als hauptberuf
haben ich habe einen riesenrespekt und
ich bin absolut bei ihnen ich glaube wir
haben noch nicht verstanden in welche
nur diese menschen gerade sich befinden
und auch wenn wir entspannt mit corona
umgehen die lage in den krankenhäusern
ist sehr sehr sehr ernst und da erwarte
ich hoffe appellierte dafür dass mehr
respekt und vor allem mal gehört nämlich
jedes beispiel jan josef liefers nur
einmal als beispiel raus als sie jan
josef liefers hat ja die aktion alles
dicht machen und dann wurde ja
eingeladen wenn er da so soll er sich
mal ehrlich gesagt was hätte er da
machen sollen also hätte dann sagen sie
nein ich komme nicht das wäre wirklich
gab in seiner position dann zu sagen sie
haben recht ich stehe zwar zu meiner
meinung aber ich komme er hat dann ja
auch danach darüber noch ein artikel
geschrieben hat über das impfen darin
gesprochen ich finde er wurde eingeladen
das heißt eine klinik wollte dass er
kommt die wollten also dass er mediale
aufmerksamkeit darauf zieht und dann hat
er zugesagt ich finde dass in der
hinsicht
einjährigen das sind aber durch die
gleichen kliniken die im grunde genommen
die kollegen die ihnen die realität
bieten nämlich die diese jeden tag haben
wenn sie auf die straße gehen wenn sie
demonstrieren wenn sie sagen das ist gar
nicht für uns das ist für das leben
derer die wir pflegen dass wir auf der
straße stehen da wird weggeguckt so real
wie man es denn doch nicht haben und die
frage beantworten was machen die
überhaupt sondern das wird dann medial
auch gepusht denn klinik jeder konzern
kann sich damit auch so ein bisschen
hoch ja was aber er schafft
aufmerksamkeit ich finde das gar nicht
so schlecht wenn so ein promi der
bekanntes gesicht hat wenn der sozusagen
auf diesen pflegeberuf der wirklich
brutal anstrengend ist sozusagen einfach
die öffentliche wahrnehmung dahin lenkt
wenn es nur für den augenblick ist und
weil die frauen und männer die im beruf
tätig sind auf die stillen leute sind
jeden tag an dienst verrichten und gar
nicht die laute stimme erheben können
dann hilft das dann hilft das doch es
hilft wenn er mal auf ski
haben
haben sie doch gerade gesagt seit 25
tagen mit demonstriert und die rheinauer
der ansatz gesagt aber es ist doch so
dass die nicht leise sind das ist doch
nur so dass niemand hingeht und paar
jahre aber das bekannte gesicht schafft
aufmerksamkeit schafft reflektion in die
gesellschaft und dann können wir die
themen ansprechen dann müssen die frauen
da kann sie ab prominente und gehören
sowieso wer bei kledy hat einige
prominente gesichter die in der
gesellschaft überhaupt gar nicht
gescheitert will die sie über das
weltliche realität doch nicht
akzeptieren ich meine das ist wirklich
nach eineinhalb jahre dass wir immer
noch nach aufmerksamkeit suchen um die
diese note die diese menschen tagtäglich
erleben eltern wie sichtbar zu machen
das geht nicht da sitzen hier politiker
da muss irgendetwas passieren wir können
nicht erwarten dass diese leute kaputt
gehe ja 23 jahren und wir warten immer
noch auf verpasst haben ja und deshalb
braucht die frage weiter unterstützung
ist er richtig da ist jetzt in der
letzten wahlperiode vom
gesundheitsminister eine menge passiert
da ist schon aber wir sind noch lange
nicht angekommen wichtiger weiß arbeit
aber nochmal jeder schritt ich will das
auch gar nicht so reden meine schwester
ist selbst krankenschwester ich werde
wird diskutieren das auch zu hause jeden
tag sie ist nicht in der pflege ist also
op krankenschwester tätig aber trotzdem
sind es ähnliche themen besprochen
werden aber jeder schritt in die politik
verbessern ist ein richtiger schritt in
die richtige richtung dass die
betroffenen sagen das reicht noch lange
nicht aus wir sind am limit wir haben zu
wenig nach wir kriegen doch zu wenig
geld und die leute diskutieren über ihre
beiträge bei dass vermessungen alles was
man erkennen diese themen müssen auf den
tischen müssen behandelt werden wenn sie
öffentlich diskutiert werden ist es
besser als wenn im stillen kämmerlein
jeder für sich alleine wenn ich eine
sache mal anmerken darf noch hinzufügen
darf zu dem was sie sagen also und ich
sehe ihre empörung sie reden von
prominenten die aber keiner wahrnimmt
dann sind es keine prominenten also das
ist ja quasi dominanz naja aber gar
nicht so sehr für liefers ist doch nur
das beste beispiel der kukksi das an der
berichtet sogar danach darüber ein sagt
so geschrieben wie anstrengend dieser
job ist also mehr werbung für ihren
beruf mehr aufmerksamkeit können sie gar
nicht bekommen ich glaube wenn wir
einmal über die frage der bezahlung nur
sprechen bei diesem extrem schwierigen
job das will ich gar nicht klein reden
dann wissen sie aber genauso gut wie
alle hier am tisch das die pflegeberufe
in letzten zehn jahren massiv
lohnmässig nach umgang sind keine
branche hat so dazu gelegt wie die
pflegeberufe bis zu 38 in zehn jahren
laut statistischem bundesamt der
durchschnitt in den zehn jahren von 210
bis 220 war plus 21 prozent und wir
reden hier um bis zu 38 prozent also
auch da ist ja schon wie herr moore ja
gerade sagte extrem viel passiert kommen
wir einfach zu dem punkt dass man sich
mal anguckt wann man fliegende in
sendungen holt mal abgesehen von mir man
holt sie wenn sie emotionale bilder
liefern sollen wenn sie sich ein
bisschen empören sollen ja wenn die
kollegen die politiker an die kandare
nehmen sollen weil das einfach ein guter
show effekt ist und danach sind sie
wieder weg und man kann durchaus mal
anfangen von einem anderen fokus ran zu
gehen und zu sagen okay was können uns
die profis dahinter eigentlich an fakten
liefern damit wir das phänomen verstehen
da fängt das an dass man besser
zusammenarbeiten muss in fast jedem
artikel den ich lese steht pflegerin man
macht sich ja nicht mal die mühe die
korrekten berufsbezeichnungen zu holen
und ok es mag sein dass die branche
gerade so ein bisschen dazu gewonnen hat
aber
6,9 millionen überstunden sind von der
altenpflege und abgegolten geleistet
worden da kann man mir nicht ganz so gut
zwar ist es nicht überall beim
handwerker in der medien- richter
schuldig gebe ihnen recht man sollte
sich für die bezeichnung zeitung aber
beim handwerker steht auch meistens
handwerker bei uns würde jetzt auch
nicht bei beiden stehen wir jetzt
politik duales wirtschaftsjournalist
oder meisten stehen auf dem funk gesagt
es tut mir leid ich verstehe es nicht
ich weiß nicht was sie genau wollen als
sie wollen aufmerksamkeit aber sie
wollen nicht die aufmerksamkeit die sie
bisher kriegen weil sie sagen das ist
dann zu effekthascherisch also welche
aufmerksamkeit wollen sie eine
fachlichkeit erst einmal reinbringen weg
von dieser emotionalität weg von dieser
verliebt und das so machen was bedeutet
fachlichkeit mal weg davon dass pflege
etwas liebliches ist wofür man ganz viel
herz und aufmerksamkeit und diesen
schwester stephanie schmitz hat und sich
einfach mal fragen ok worum geht es
eigentlich wenn pflegende über
gesellschaft reden und wenn man anfang
will zu begreifen was dieser
gesellschaft alles entgeht weil man
diesen beruf nicht vernünftig entwickelt
und nicht an internationale
gegebenheiten anpasst dann würde man
aber richtig blass werden und dann würde
man auch ganz schnell sagen okay ich
nenne die lieber so wie sie gelernt
haben und wie sie heißen weil ich dann
einfach auch begreife was sie geleistet
haben es gibt keine krankenschwestern
mehr seit 2004 und es gibt eine ganze
bandbreite eine pflegerin kann immer
auch um meistens wenn sie skandalisiert
wird eine pflegehelferin sein das ist
nicht das gleiche wie jemand der noch
fünf jahre drauf pflege studiert hat ist
nicht das gleiche kann man nicht in
einen topf werfen und da fängt einfachen
mechanismus an mit dem ich nicht
verstehe es gibt trotzdem noch eine
menge berufskollegen von ihnen die sie
in die politischen talkshows geschafft
da weil ich eine alexander jorde denke
zum beispiel der war damals der erste
der in so ein sondern diskussionsrunde
die kanzlerin mit dem thema pflege
konfrontiert ich folge den seitdem auf
twitter glaube ich weil ich das
spannende wie er sich der mutig geäußert
hat und sein problem von seiner
berufsgruppe sozusagen in die
öffentlichen diskurs gebracht hat und
der kritisiert bis zum heutigen tag aus
seiner sicht bestimmt richtig was noch
nicht alles geschafft wurde in der
pflege aber da ist jemand der es aus
fachlicher sicht macht die da es im
alltag berichtet der sagt wo sie am
grenzen sind wo sie am limit sind in der
klinik und dann kommt es immer darauf an
was die bezahlung betrifft das ist er
sich auch wenn träger zu träger
unterschiedlich mir im osten haben immer
auch noch lohnunterschiede zwischen ost
und west das muss man mal einer erklären
im jahr 2021 31 jahre nach der
friedlichen revolution dass der
krankenpflegerinnen und krankenpfleger
unterschiedliches gehalt kriegen wo so
der unterschied liegen manchmal kommen
ja immer die diskussion das liegt an der
produktivität aber das möchte ich ja
sehen wo
[Musik]